Senator John fetterman who is the
Democrat senator from Pennsylvania he
remains hospitalized John Federman has
been in the hospital now since February
16th it's almost April and he checked
himself into the hospital because he
apparently is suffering from depression
this though as a result of a major
stroke on the campaign Trail and then
potentially some other Strokes or
stroke-like symptoms so he's been in
there for six weeks and the doctors say
he might remain hospitalized for another
two weeks they keep saying another two
weeks another two weeks and they're
saying he's going to remain hospitalized
for another two weeks to get his
medication exactly right obviously wish
Senator fetterman very well he doesn't
belong in the Senate he should be home
recovering it's horrible with the
Democrats and what his family have done
to him and they should allow the man to
step down and take care of his health in
peace but they're not going to do that
so they're going to try to tweak all of
these powerful psych drugs to get him to
just the right spot where he can sit in
the Senate and give a reliable vote to
Chuck Schumer and Joe Biden